كانت كلها كانت تصب في صالح استغرب كما
تعلم الاول انا في رايي
اصبحت
في زواج كبار السن تتاقلم منها
معارضه قويه
وان شاء الله يعني الجايه ان شاء الله ما
فيش حاجه يعني من حق كل واحد يعترف الواحد
من هو ان يبدي رايه في المائه محترمه مش
مساله انه احنا كل يوما نجيب رئيس يعني
التهديد
في العالم هو الشعب المصري في الاخر يعني
يعني كنا نتمنى صوره مر علينا يعني بيصير
لكنها ماشي كده مرور سنتين بالضبط ما فيش
جديد حتى يعني اقترب من سبعه دولار دي
الوقتي اكثر من سبقني بالنسبه لل المصري
الاقتصاد الخطر الشعب المصري كله خاطر
الحقيقه الثوره المصريه هي ثوره العرب
كلها واحنا لا ننتظر ان الثوره سنه الزمان
ستعطي كل ثمارها ابتداء الثوره لتغيير
الطواغيت وبعد ذلك لبناء المؤسسات المدنيه
وست عم الثوره والديمقراطيه والمؤسسات
المدنيه لكل الوطن العربي من مصر الوضع في
مصر اه اربعه اعوام لهون فيها العام
الموضوع انه مصر اه في خمسين سنه تقريبا
من دعم الديمقراطيه والحريات ومصر زائد
فساد بشكل اه ضخم جدا
العوامل الاجتماعيه
اه ضخمه مع الفساد ونحن على مقربه
من الاحتفال بالعام الثاني لخمسه وعشرين
يناير
تظل هناك حاله من الانفلات السياسي في مصر
هناك حاله من عدم التوافق السياسي في
اه
الرئيس وبين بعض
من الحكومه اه
يعني اعتقد انه اه يعني مشتبه احتفاليه
احيانا الثوره وتكملتها
واظن
الايام الغضب بدات من اول النهار ده
اظن الايام اللي جايه
اتسمت حلا كثير جدا
ام